the politics and the ideology and all
the conflict it's divided people and we
want our monuments we are being pushed
around by the federal government
today I'm signing a new executive order
to end another egregious abuse of
federal power nice be nice
we met the slanter survival
[Music]
I'm driving through the gorgeous
sprawling landscape of bears ears
national monument in Southeast Utah but
I'm not here for the views I'm here
because what's happening in Bears ears
may define the future of public land
America so how do you feel about this
designation of bears ears as a National
Monument it's done by our enemies is
done by our foes and all that all the
narrative about it is that we're looters
were grave robbers we're racists we hate
the federal government we hate public
land and that's that's wrong there's a
fight brewing in the West over who
controls public land and who profits
from it revealing America's deep
divisions over wealth race and ideology
bears ears is emerging as the defining
battle at the end of his presidency
Obama used the 1906 law called the
antiquities Act to create the new
National Monument
but just after taking office President
Trump ordered a review of all large
national monuments designated since 1996
the federal government asserted this
power over 1.3 five million acres of
land in Utah known as bears ears the
review covers all monuments going back
to the Clinton administration and could
open up America's most beloved monuments
to development and extraction industries
some even wearing national parks could
follow we're getting half oil and gas
development and protect places like
bears ears but in this ideology age of
nobody listens to anybody it's hard to
have those good conversations the lines
are drawn in this Western standoff with
Pro monument groups like
environmentalists the outdoor industry
Native Americans and archaeologists
while those standing against the
monument include local politicians
hunters and trappers mining and oil
industries and now the Trump
administration
[Music]
the antiquities Act does not give the
federal government unlimited power to
lock up millions of acres of land and
water and it's time we ended this
abusive practice Trump left the details
to his newly appointed interior
secretary Ryan's Enki tasked with
reviewing 27 national monuments in just
120 days this is the first time that the
president has ever commissioned a or
signed an executive order to review and
President Trump who was a great boss to
work for by the way President Trump has
tasked me to review monuments sworn in
on March 1st Zinke announced he would
head to Utah to determine the fate of
bears news with issues of race ideology
and the economy on the line the people
of Utah anxiously awaited his arrival
we love tourism we you know we welcome
people but the things that keeps the
schools funded and the county funded and
growth is really the extraction industry
for Lyman and other politicians in Utah
the feds have been in an unwelcome
landlord for decades we are being pushed
around by the federal government yeah
and we we're not oblivious to it like I
say even a dog distinguishes between
being tripped over and being kicked and
we're being kicked by the federal
government today
ninety-three percent of federal land is
in 13 western states accounting for
nearly half the land in Oregon more than
half is federal in Nevada it's more than
80 percent in Utah 64.5% is federal
another five percent is tribal and ten
percent is controlled by the state
given this it's easy to see why some
people are concerned with federal land
control in the West protests against the
federal government over public land
issues have turned violent in recent
years in 2014 a dispute over cattle
grazing fees escalated into an armed
standoff between federal law enforcement
and those supporting rancher cliven
Bundy if I worked cliven and I like him
I like his spirit his spunk and I like
the people that you know there's oil I
do like him I respect him he got to go
and cut a good deal right now that's the
best thing that could happen for
everybody and in 2016 our militants led
by clive and son amon seized a Wildlife
Refuge in Oregon over our ranching
dispute on public land take a guy like
Ammon Bundy who says you know this
doesn't sit well with me I don't think I
can face my maker at the end of this at
the end of this probation not having
done something so in that way I feel
exactly the same Liman garnered national
attention for an ATV protest ride just
outside of bears ears he was sentenced
to ten days in jail for the stunts the
ATV ride May 2014 and recapture Canyon
near Blanding protesting the BLM's
closure of a trail two vehicles to
preserve archaeology my conscience
approves my conduct Phil Lyman then and
after sentencing Friday after my
prosecution and going to jail I said
I don't I don't have anything against
the BLM employees I think they're good
people but there's a culture there
there's a culture of kind of imperialism
it's a domination thing and people
historically don't don't put up with
that for very long numerous Native
American groups spoke out against the
ATV ride arguing it disturbed ancestral
archaeological sites and played into a
long hostile racial history in the area
the Navajo Nation sued the county in
2011 over racially motivated
redistricting and again in 2016
over claims of violations of the 1965
Voting Rights Act there was even a local
disinformation campaign using fake
posters to make environmentalists seem
racist do you think there's there's
hints of racism in the way that it's
playing out well if you were raised
around here you know that's the way it
is I met up with a Navajo Nation
spiritual leader named Johnny Elliman
and asked him how it feels to know that
bears ears might be rescinded that's a
diamond makes me worried
why how come through trying to do this
like I said is it is it because we're
Native after having been invited to the
table during the Obama administration a
reversal would be a slap in the face the
first time ever as Native our voices
wouldn't hurt people say there's nothing
out there what do you what do you what
do you crying bought that you know why
are you arguing about that land for
there's nothing out there there is
something not there it's so spiritual
out there you know so when you go back
that way you won't see that two months
after his swearing-in Zinke still hadn't
arrived and locals in support of the
monument were getting suspicious even
more concerning were recent pushes to
see federal lands to state control and
possibly sell them off to the highest
bidder
Utah congressman jason Chaffetz faced an
outcry after proposing just that earlier
this year what we're trying to do is
find a balanced approach you how about
to our recreationists you have
conservation needs you have energy
development you have
[Applause]
the reality is we can have our cake and
eat it too we can have recreation and we
can have oil and gas development we just
need to do it in the right places like
you don't do oil and gas development in
places they're gonna ruin your tourism
economy
Josh Ewing is executive director of a
nonprofit organization that lobbied for
the monument he was driven in part by a
passion for climbing this is a
world-famous place for recreation and
the outdoor industry doesn't want to see
that become industrialized for outdoor
companies dependent on public land for
recreation the issue has become heated
and political it's official after two
decades the Outdoor Retailer show
leaving the state of Utah the outdoor
industry has been doing the Outdoor
Retailer show for almost 20 years up in
Salt Lake City brings something like 50
million dollars a year to the Utah
economy and because of the state's
insistence to undo the Bears ears
National Monument outdoor industry
decided to move to a state that's more
friendly toward public lands to the
governor's office releasing a statement
tonight about an hour ago calling the
decision offensive
for many who grew up in the area it has
always felt like the Old West they
hunted where they wanted bulldoze new
roads camp tour ever but now their
backyard has become more crowded public
Gladys for everybody it's not the
government land it's a public land to
enjoy the land of many uses
the use of us what's God put here to do
like the uranium and the oil and stuff
it's here for a reason
one local opposed the monument is punk
holiday who says the designation could
seriously affect this construction
business
we have gravel pits and three of our
main gravel pits are in the monument
he often uses the land to hunt and I
tagged along one morning as he drove the
back roads looking for Mountain Lion
tracks okay let's build right he'll take
it you'll hit the other road up there
but I know that they'll do way up this
road yeah what's our guns ease and you
lose twenty two pistols really it's what
I always pack pistol yeah the dogs
caught the scent of a mountain lion in
late morning the lion said no wrong tree
sprawl that across there
let me go to shoot they will send the
cameras off coz some of these animal
rights people that get a little upset
with me
punk is worried hunting could be banned
along with other local uses of the land
like cutting trees for firewood and
camping not to mention the direct effect
on his business my belief is that a lot
of local folks that have been here for a
long time they felt like it was their
own personal backyard cuz no one else
was around Native Americans have also
been concerned about traditional uses of
the lands like collecting herbs or
cutting firewood could be curtailed
before they go huntin they go
sweat-lodge traditional practices were
guaranteed in the presidential
proclamation and in a historic first
obama established a tribal commission to
help manage the land this bears national
monument is the first time a union of
tribes have come together set aside
their differences and ask the federal
government to protect their lands and
got listened to like the top guy in the
land said you know what that's probably
a good point we know we kicked you off
these lands we know that they're
important to you maybe we ought to
listen to you and protect them and now
folks are saying you know what we don't
care if that lands important to you we
don't know care if it's sacred to you we
want it unprotected and to me that's
really sad for the Native American
tribes in the region the National
Monument is a sacred landscape full of
ancient burial sites homes and sweat
lodges it's been preserved for
generations to come
that's what we did now before that you
know there was a looting going on there
was desecrating there was a target
practicing on these up in the cliffs
Kevin Jones Utah's former State
Archaeologist Tomi looting has been a
major problem artifacts found on private
land are fair game so it can be hard to
trace what was taken off public lands
there is rarely a sheltered site like a
rock shelter or cave site that hasn't
been significantly plundered ancient
people who lived here made beautiful
bowls and pots baskets and those things
can be very very valuable to collectors
and others and unfortunately I asked
Punk Holliday what he thought about the
local tradition of pot hunting my
parents house was raided and my dad and
his uncle have the buy one of the
biggest collections around a lot of it
probably majority I was on private
property there around planning for the
east digging to find the stuff before
zinc you came to Utah he had a private
meeting with a local County
Commissioners in Washington DC tribal
leaders came to DC as well but he
refused to meet with them with no
response from Zinke Pro monument groups
organize the protest rally before he
even arrived we want our Monument alone
[Applause]
when Zinke finally flew down to see
bears ears for the first time protests
followed and Native American leaders
were left outside
even right now a lot of people being
turned away over here at the road and a
lot of presence of the police and it's
just the way the county has treated
Navin secretaries inky did finally meet
with tribal leaders in Utah but it only
lasted for one hour afterward he held
the press conference without them as
protesters chanted on the streets below
yes sir thank you for coming down here
and talking to us
Oh the overwhelming majority of Native
Americans that we spoken to down in the
area are adamantly opposed the money was
being rescinded and they say that if it
happens it's yet another example of
their rights and their sovereignty being
trampled how do you respond to that
there is distrust of previous efforts
that the tribe and tribes in this case
aren't perfect remarkably that's the
same argument I hear from many counties
and and many elected officials that the
federal government by and large has not
heard the local voice the Hopi Tribe
Navajo Nation you mountain ute tribe
Pueblo of Zuni and hue Indian tribe
spent years lobbying for the monument
was Zinke overseeing the Bureau of
Indian Affairs his unwillingness to get
priority to sovereign Native American
tribes came off as particularly
insulting here at the various National
Monument where a lot of activists and
protesters have gathered in defense of
National Monument as you can see
oppressor here looks like Winkie just
pulled up
[Music]
be nice you had a brief interact with us
in with the secretaries you want to tell
us I was scared I was scared when he
came at me afterward I spoke with Joni
yellow man again do you feel like the
secretary Zinke is making an effort to
talk to native groups and then try to
understand where they're coming from
we want him to come out and listen to it
the natives themself
go down go down with us go down to where
we live and look at that land you know
where we do our offerings where we do
our prayers what we use you know for
medicine and all the beauty nurses out
there and listen to my people my elders
you know they've been living there we
use that land we are the first users of
that land that's what I wanted to tell
you
[Music]
hey this is danny goal with aj+ you can
check out the rest of our divided
America series where we examine the tech
elite embracing the prepper movement
refugees fleeing the US for Canada
the battle over land rights in America
and the attempt to defund Planned
Parenthood right now on the aj+ youtube
channel thanks for watching
[Music]